hey everyone it's for Escalante here
from Animal Planet's extinct you're
alive I'm a wildlife biologist and
you're watching the breakdown
[Music]
first up Ace Ventura check this out look
at that that's a true albino pigeon
some rich guy lost it he's offering a
$25,000 reward so I'm gonna pause it
right there it's pretty funny just off
the start if you're somebody who lives
in a city anywhere you know that there's
nothing that uncommon about seeing a
white pigeon you know you see them every
day so just the fact that in this clip a
venturi is looking for a rare albino
pigeon that's worth 25 grand is
absolutely hilarious so it's a good
start
[Music]
it's just so much fun you know the whole
idea that Ace Ventura can wiggle the
keys and all of the animals in his house
that you know he's rescued or he lives
among we'll all go and hide into various
spots it's ridiculous it's not how it
works it's not our animals work doesn't
matter if you're the best trained
creatures in the world maybe you could
get the odd dog to do it but to get you
know this cacophony of creatures that
all live in this tiny one-bedroom
apartment to all go and hide it it's
absurd it's hilarious it's not realistic
at all and it's a ton of fun as Ace
Ventura blows the whistle the first
thing you see is the beagle coming
running out the dog there's a toucan in
the frame there's a whole bunch of South
American parrots which is hilarious
of course these are common you know
birds in the pet trade but you certainly
wouldn't want to have that many of them
living in a small apartment now my
favorite part of the the opening of this
scene is the otter coming out of the
toilet that's an Asian small-clawed
otters they're absolutely hilarious
super inquisitive of everything and how
unrealistic these clips are the most
realistic part of this is probably an
Asian small-clawed otters hiding and
playing in a toilet because they're just
so mischievious they're so playful
there's so much fun they would
absolutely hide in the toilet and pop
out like that I love that clip it's
super cute now this is a trained animal
and each one of these animals that
you're seeing are indeed trained animals
so it's amazing that they're capable of
doing this on command for the camera but
it doesn't mean that they all did it you
know in simultaneity when the whistle
was blown it doesn't work that way you
can be sure that when they were setting
this up they probably spent a day
getting the skunk to pop out of the
laundry and another day getting all the
birds to fly in and another day getting
the Asian small-clawed otters a pop out
of the toilet so it's beautifully done
it's really clever filmmaking but it's
not the way that animals work the notion
that this many creatures of this diverse
of species could all live in a single
one-bedroom apartment is pretty
ridiculous
that being said animals are incredible
and they're adaptive and they're very
very trainable and they're very
understanding like could you have otters
and parrots and puppies and skunks all
living together absolutely there's no
big predators in that group so they
could all live in harmony but they
couldn't all live in harmony in a
one-bedroom apartment that's ooh there's
just not enough space for the amount of
animals you're seeing so Ace Ventura pet
detective
absolutely awesome movie everyone should
watch it it's tons of
and it makes you love animals but
ridiculous to think that that many
creatures could all be crammed happily
into a one-bedroom apartment
next up anaconda
now if you're working with anacondas
they don't have that build you know they
don't have that kind of flexibility that
you're seeing what you're seeing in this
frame here is this animal has maybe the
back 1/8 of its body up in that whatever
building structure is and the rest of it
it's holding up with this body weight
that's unrealistic those animals are not
capable of doing that all they can do is
hold about 1/3 of their body up and off
the ground at a time the front third and
so seeing as maybe that's you know six
or seven eighths of its body being held
up it's unrealistic it's too skinny and
it's too long that's not the way
anacondas look for a second so there's
two species of anaconda there's green
anacondas and there's yellow anacondas
now what I'm seeing here is is neither
really it's it's I don't know you know I
can see what they're going for they're
trying to make this look like the green
anaconda but it's it's got too much red
it's too dark you know maybe maybe if
the snake we're about to shed and it was
really really old it would have that
darker coloration but really it looks
too dark and the eyes look too humanoid
that's not a reptilian eye and you can
see why they've done that as human
beings as bipedal creatures when we look
at another animal we connect to them
through you know eyesight through ocular
vision and so when you see bigger meaner
looking eyes like what they put on the
snake it's instantly scarier than when
you see the actual snakes eyes which are
far more kind of peaceful looking than
this animals
hold it there for a second so as you see
the snake wraps up with the back third
of its body to coil its victim now
there's two pieces today the one part
that's accurate is anacondas are indeed
constrictors they will absolutely wrap
their prey asphyxiate it by crushing the
ribcage and then consume it but they
will never ever lead with their tail
they do not have the ability to do that
when a constrictor snake attacks its
prey it leads with its head latches on
to something and then uses that grip
with its mouth to then wrap around its
prey or victim so the notion that it can
just kind of use its tail like Indiana
Jones whip and wrap around and then
continue to do something else with its
head is well it's just silly
all there for a sec now what you're
hearing is an anaconda screaming that's
a real piece of movie magic for you
right there ladies and gentlemen because
there's no such thing you know I've
caught hundreds of anacondas I really
have and none of them have ever gone her
and growled or screamed at me they just
don't do that the most noise that that
animal is capable of making is releasing
air from its body to let out the hissing
sound that we're familiar with in snakes
which is like a bit of a sound but this
whole notion that it growls and grunts
as it's fighting with this guy it's just
it's just complete add in audio so now
what you see is the snakes trapped in
this net right but it's still got its
two victims within its coil oh you're
really anthropomorphizing the animal
here and what I mean by that is this
thing's out for vengeance right it's not
even there to eat the its prey the two
people it's there just to kill them
that's why it won't even let them go in
a net well if you've ever caught any
kind of wild animal you know the second
that it's under stress it doesn't want
it continue to try and feed it doesn't
want to continue to try and tact it
wants to get away these are all things
very far from real life but if this
situation were to happen in real life
where you were being constricted by an
anaconda and it hadn't latched on you
with its teeth and you were trapped in a
net the second that's something dramatic
like gunfire and nets were coming up and
around it it would release and do
everything in its power to get away hold
there now the speed is really really
interesting so the reason that anacondas
get so big is because they live a long
time anacondas like many reptiles grow
until the day they die right as you get
bigger and bigger it makes it harder and
harder to move it takes more energy
expenditure so the largest anacondas
that I've ever caught the 21 plus
footers are so big and so heavy that out
of water they can barely slither I mean
it's like you can see the amount of
effort going into every motion and here
we have our 60 foot long anaconda of
course it's three times the size of
anything in reality but it's moving it
there's a lightning speed
first of all two bites bad a bite from
big snake sucks they have a recurve
tooth system like this and when it goes
down they interlock and then you're
stuck within those T's so you really
don't want to end up with a bite from a
big boa or a big Python like an anaconda
that being said the bites not the part
that'll do damage sure you're going to
take these three inch long recurve
needles into your body but it's the
coiling and the asphyxiation that
creates a problem you can get an
anaconda to release from you or any
snake for that matter by wedging
something in its mouth and prying it
open but if you're attacked by a big
snake like this or a realistic one you
got to get your buddies which I've had
do to me a couple times run around
uncoiling the thing as it's trying to
wrap you up because that's the dangerous
part if the snake feels like it's being
attacked it's not going to continue to
try and consume you the only reason a
big snake is holding on to you is
because it's trying to eat you otherwise
it's a defensive bike it's a strike bite
and release on their own so if you're in
the situation where they're already
coiling up it's because you're
restraining it and it's trying to do
some damage or because it's trying to
eat of everything I've seen the most
realistic kind of bite and coil you see
the snake there lunges forward he grabs
a guy by the shoulder pulls him back
into his own body and starts to wrap
around him that's actually how the
snakes do behave very different to what
you saw earlier where it used the back
half of its body like a whip just to
wrap around that's that's complete
nonsense this is at least anatomically
somewhat correct
hold there for a second this is actually
pretty good the teeth aren't bad they're
relatively anatomically correct what I
was talking about earlier they're
backwards-facing there's a lot of them
which is right now these snakes can open
their mouths up wider than the width of
their body what you're seeing him get
ready to do here to consume the guy it's
actually not bad whoever whoever
scripted this probably had actually seen
a snake eat something before
I've never been inside a snake so I
don't know how real that is so when a
constrictor consumes its food it's
almost always completely dead in this
case the guy's feet are literally
wiggling as he goes down the snakes
throat so you know no animal would do
that at risk of injury to themselves
because if they're going to consume
something that's clawing and scratching
on the way down it's going to do damage
to vital internal organs so you know
again we're back to a little bit of
Hollywood magic but at least it's
somewhat anatomically correct they do
feed from the head down not from the
legs up so that part's right he would go
down headfirst there would be that kind
of bit of gulping that you're seeing the
snake do that parts all accurate but the
reality is the prey would already be
killed by asphyxiation before the snake
ADA and then as you see as the prey goes
down in this case the guy its body's
actually expanding to the the size of
the meal and that's accurate as well
snakes will do that if you feed a snake
something it can eat something larger
than its own head because it's jaw can
stretch so much and their skin is
stretchy enough that they can actually
consume things bigger than them and
you'll see that big lump in them as it
goes down so in this case what would
typically happen is a big snake eats a
big meal like that it's gonna get pretty
lethargic it's gonna settle down it
actually can't have that meal disrupted
too much if it does it'll regurgitate it
because there's so much whole food in
there it slowly has to kind of let the
muscles work the prey down and get to
the stomach acids which will dissolve
everything including bone the animal has
to kind of chill in order to do that so
you can't have a snake that's gulping
down you know a huge meal aka guy and
then turning around to gulp down the
next three because it's just too much
energy they're not really capable of
that
now those are real anacondas for the
first time so that's kind of nice to see
in that scene
we've gone from our monster CG anaconda
to a couple real green anacondas as
you're likely from a zoo or a captive
breeding facility and you can see the
difference in what I was saying earlier
you know the coloration you can see the
marketing they're not jet black with
those evil eyes they're a nice you know
pale green color and they're very
beautiful they're very sleek they're
very shiny and there we have the
regurgitation I was talking about so
this is I don't want to say correct but
it's not too far-fetched if a snake were
to eat a big meal like a guy like that
you know of course it would kill him and
then if it got bumped and it was running
around there's too much energy exertion
it would just throw it back up so
watching this scene from anaconda look
it's not my favorite it may demonize his
snakes one of my favorite animals they
shouldn't be demonized
it's very fabricated for Hollywood the
behavior of the animal the way it whips
its tail around the way it's out to
actually get someone its silliness it's
not real that being said there's a
couple relatively anatomically correct
things the kind of shape of the animal
the way that it does constrict its prey
the way that it bites the way it has
recurved teeth all those things are
correct so it's a little bit of a
balance but overall it's not for the
best
next up the revenue
Hair scare me man I'll tell you I've
worked with a lot of wildlife and bears
are they're tough and what you see here
the idea that Leonardo DiCaprio is
hunting and he's kind of dropped his
guard and all of a sudden the ferns
start moving in this animal charges
totally realistic now the bear looks a
little CG but the behavior totally
realistic you could be out in the woods
especially up in the far north you're
out hunting the Bears on to you it could
be in the springtime when they're trying
to store up fat so they're willing to
risk their own bodies in order to hunt a
large meal like a human being or you
know a caribou or something like that
and this whole idea of it hunting you
charging out of the bush totally now the
way he's mauling Leonardo DiCaprio again
seems pretty realistic to me he's on top
of them he's overpowering him now bears
are highly intelligent and they know if
they're making a kill that's the way to
do that so again it looks pretty real
he's digging in with his claws he's
doing a lot of damage in as efficient a
manner as possible without letting any
damage be inflicted on himself so that
is the way a bear would attack I mean
this is a CG bear but it's obviously
supposed to be a grizzly or a brown bear
you know black bears are much smaller
they wouldn't behave in this manner
they're far more timid this is clearly
supposed to be a grizzly bear as opposed
to CG sounds like in some of the other
clips these are actual bear sounds that
have been put in now they may have been
kind of stretched and and and warped a
little bit to fit the scene but these
are real bear noises so the bear is
attacking like that it's going to cut
very very deeply not just because of the
sharpness of the teeth and the sharpness
of the claws but rather the jaw pressure
and the immense amount of strength that
that animal is putting into it the teeth
and claws they're sharp but they're no
sharper than like your puppy dogs at
home it's just they have so much
strength behind those teeth and claws
that that amount of damage is I mean
they're gouging really really good
now this part I kind of don't understand
and what I mean by that is the Bears
just standing over him now I'm not to
say that that couldn't happen cuz it
could you know bear could be tired from
making the kill tired from the mauling
and just catching its breath just
admiring its prey but I don't know if it
would need to necessarily this wasn't
like a big battle for the bear he kind
of caught Leo pinned him down beat him
up now it's time to eat and he's not
he's just standing there for a second it
almost feels a little a little bit too
prolonged but certainly not outside of
the realm of reality a bear is gonna
attack for two reasons right the least
likely is that it sees you as a prey
source that's very unlikely the more
likely one is that it's a defensive
aggressive attack and what I mean by
that is say this is a sow a female and
she has a couple cubs nearby she will
absolutely attack to defend her cubs she
thinks you're another big predator and
you are as human beings we're apex
predators that could be the case here
where the attack is simply a mauling
it's almost like a warning that does a
lot of damage and then she's going to
leave it she doesn't want to eat you she
wants to move on so when a bear attacks
there's two mentalities really if it's a
black bear you want to be loud you want
to be aggressive and you want to be
dominant and the reason being they're a
little bit smaller and they're far more
timid and shy a grizzly bear like this
the accepted idea is that you play dead
and because once you play dead the
animal is done expressing dominance
right it no longer feels threatened by
your presence so she's gonna leave you
alone and go back to her cub so if it
comes in you can keep quiet and go limp
obviously really hard to do let the bear
attack happen then the idea is she will
retreat go back to her cubs and you can
get up and run away you can hear the
Cubs in the background great so what
that tells me straight away this mother
did not attack out of predation she
wasn't trying to eat Leonardo DiCaprio
because she was starving
instead she felt threatened by his
presence as another predator in her
habitat and she's protecting her young
so now she's come in she's mold him he's
rightfully played dead or he's so
injured that he's seems like he's dead
and the Bears beginning to retreat now
it looks to me like Leo begins to kind
of sit up and say what's going on is she
gone and that prompts another attack
right she turns around and charges
I think as he does as anyone naturally
what he has a firearm any any fires and
so that of course you know inflicts
injury upon the bear and provokes an
ongoing attack so overall in the
revenant I would say the bear attack is
the most accurate one that I've seen of
all the clips today
all right the gray here so now you know
now I'm gonna really rip them apart
because when you see anaconda you can
kind of forgive the bad CG from 1997 I
think the gray was made like two years
ago it's hard to forgive such bad animal
CG in this day and age when you got
things like Avatar where you're like wow
this is incredible and the first scene
of the grey where I'm seeing this here
you've got this terrible black CG wolf
with the dripping fangs and the the
huffing and puffing of breath I mean it
it's truly we've created a monster this
is more of a werewolf than a real wolf
and that's that's a bit sad because this
is supposed to be telling a story of
actual wolves so this guy is doing the
absolute wrong thing here he's low to
the ground he's making eye contact with
the animal and then he's backing up like
you couldn't do anything worse if you're
threatened by a canine you know it has
one-on-one standoff situation like that
you make yourself big you lower your
gaze so that you're not challenging it
because when you make eye contact with a
canine specifically a wolf you're
challenging it that's a threat display
the drop eye contact say leave me alone
you know get big and get loud and let
the animal retreat by being low to the
ground you're being small you're not
intimidating and by retreating that
instantly triggers the attack response
because it says I'm prey I'm scared of
you right if you're ever faced with an
apex predator you want to show them
you're the boss
whereas if you retreat straight away
they go I'm in charge so he's small he's
retreating and he's threatening it like
he's doing everything wrong if you were
faced with this situation
you got five-year buddies hanging out
and you're all staring off a wolf if
they all got loud and advanced that that
was not gonna stick around you can't
take on five full-grown people almost
100 pounds that animal would turn in
hightail it but instead they're standing
off they're actually they're actually
inviting combat to this wall as opposed
to just being aggressive being the
Nader and and making the animal retreat
alright let's skip ahead
[Music]
there so here we see Liam Neeson he's in
the den right and we're establishing
that by movie magic we see the remains
of old animals we see the animals
underground now you can tell that he has
actually put himself in too much of a
threatening position and what I mean by
that is a mother wolf just like a mother
bear
she's gonna do everything in her power
to protect her cubs pups in this case
and you know if you're in a wolf's den
that's a very bad place to be
no longer you trying to trigger the
fight-or-flight response from the wolf
but now you're the aggressor you're
putting yourself in a position where the
mother has one option and that's to get
rid of
[Music]
they're now wolves are very social pack
animals they hunt as a pack they work
together they work in unison they use
audio communication signals and body
language signals and they're actually
doing a pretty good job of showing that
here not only do you have all of the
walls surrounding Liam the way that a
pack would when there is a single
intruder but you have the the alpha male
the dominant male the largest strongest
wolf standing on the highest ground in
the best attack position while the other
animals watch now if there's one animal
that's going to advance over the others
the first one should be that alpha then
would come into support players all of
the other animals and they know that
based on the alphas body cues now we're
back to anthropomorphizing animals we're
giving them human qualities what we're
saying is the Alpha is like our villain
from a superhero movie and he's like
alright this one's mine you know you
guys back off
no Wolf's gonna do that they're not
stupid instead his pack would stand
there and watch and he may be the first
aggressor the alpha male but then the
pack animals would join in as needed
wolves are actually the most demonized
animals throughout human history dating
all the way back into the ancient Romans
and the ancient Greeks or hieroglyphics
where a man would fight a wolf and we'd
combat a wolf all the way into cave
paintings and what's interesting is if
you look into the records of it there's
only ever been something like three
fatal wolf attacks on humans in history
in this frame right here he's showing a
lot of aggression right his brow is
furrowed his lips are curled back
expressing his teeth he's locked on his
gaze with liam neeson these are all
typical canine behaviors expressing a
challenge saying you know I'm here to
fight you and and that part's quite
accurate what's not accurate is the way
the animal looks it just doesn't look
like a wolf it's too shabby it's too
dark it's just too CG
so now another movie about wolves that I
haven't seen Alfa so that's actually you
know straight off the bat it seems more
realistic I mean one the wolves are
clearly still CG but the way that the
wolves are somewhat communicating
they're expressing dominance you could
see they're working together and they're
hunting like a pack that's how wolves do
hunt gray wolves come in a variety of
colors from basically pure white to pure
black and these grey and brown and tan
colors that you see in between you know
our minds black wolves like Black
Panthers are scarier and more evil and
that's why in Hollywood they're the
leaders and they're the biggest and
they're the meanest that's absolutely
not the case in nature
[Music]
so here you hear the animals howling as
the kids stuck in the tree it's not
unrealistic because wolves howl to
communicate and and signal to other
packs and other animals where they are
but if they've got prey cornered in a
tree they probably don't need to how
they call others over so it's kind of
pretty and it's nice I don't necessarily
know that it's what would be happening
so a second ago you saw the wolves
howling while the boy was in the tree
and then the very next scene the wolves
are all gone so that actually makes
sense right so the Wolves cornered this
kid in the tree they go F we can't can't
get him he's up there we're stuck down
here let me call and see where the rest
of the family is where the rest of the
pack is they how they here in the
distant of the packs you know three
klicks to the left I'm going that way
and they all take off but the one animal
that's left behind is of course the one
that's injured so now that's interesting
because they have a real wolf dog in
that clip meaning an animal that's a
hybrid between a real wild wolf and and
domesticated dog has more wolf traits
physically but they've used a real
animal and they painted a bit of fake
blood on it and I already like this more
than the grey because the kids showing
some compassion right he doesn't want to
just murder the wolf he knows that the
wolf's an animal it's a predator it was
trying to eat him but now it's injured
it can't eat him and they're they're
leaving each other alone I think in this
situation the wolf would be far more
terrified and aggressive I can
understand it's it's very injured and
it's probably dehydrated so it probably
doesn't have a lot of energy to be
aggressive but I think it would be
growling and snarling if someone were to
approach it keep in mind this is an
animal you know of course this is dated
very long time ago this is an animal
that's likely never done seen a human
being before alright and then he picks
up the wolf really nice so now we're
gonna fast forward a bit so now they're
buddies right he's swimming he's playing
with the wolf now it's fun and it's
enjoyable to watch but wolves are not
pets they're just not wired that way
I've worked with a lot of wolves even
domesticated wolves at no point could
you be picking up and throwing a wolf
around they still have wolf behavior
they still have pack mentality and that
would be you trying to dominate an
animal that otherwise wants to be done
here you see the wolf is dominant you
know he's far more capable of hunting
this wild boar than the kid is I love
that I love that scene you know it's
grounded in historical scientific theory
which is that wolves followed human
beings humans slowly domesticated wolves
over generations and then they work
together to hunt and feed here we've
seen it all in the span of an hour in a
movie and really it probably took many
many generations but it's great to see
the the idea the human and animal
working together to benefit each other
and that's why dogs are man's closest
friend love that absolutely love that
that they're so here you see right the
packs returned the wolf that's been with
the boy they've established a bond and
when the pack the Alpha from prior the
big black bad wolf comes in to make the
attack he sees that the other wolf has
become friends with the boy so to speak
and the body language cues allow that
other wolf to relax I don't know there
would be that instantaneous as you see
it here but the idea that these animals
are intelligent enough to say hey this
is my pack that's your pack you know
let's not fight he's very great and it's
true because animals do respond that way
especially canines that are as
intelligent as wolf
great love it yeah I think we're
learning that that's a female you see
the gray wolf that the boys been with
and then the big black wolf they stand
off and then the big black wolf drops
his guard you know the body posture
relaxed and the gray wolf comes in and
does Allah under his neck it's a mate
they subtly do that in body language and
it's nice it's well done when you
compare the gray in alpha you see one
movie that truly demonizes and
villainize as wolves and another movie
where wolf becomes man's best friend so
for me it's an easy choice as to what
the better message and the better movie
is it's the one where we respect the
animals enough to bring them into our
home and have an understanding and learn
from them it's the it's alpha
next up the shallows
[Music]
I'm going to stop there okay so there's
a couple things here first of all we
have Blake Lively on a surfboard right
she is clearly getting picked off by a
tiger shark great accurate done wrong
absolutely tiger sharks attack surfers
now tiger sharks attack a lot of things
they're known as the dumpsters the sea
right
but the reason specifically the tiger
sharks have been known to attack surfers
is because when you're dangling your
arms and your legs off your board you
look like a sea turtle and that's tiger
sharks favorite meals you look you have
a big round thing in the middle your
surfboard which looks like a shell and
your four flippers bobbing around
so when tiger sharks do attack surfers
it's when they're paddling out or
they're sitting in the lineup the notion
that this shark would actually come
through a wave risking its own safety to
attack the board is silliness it doesn't
look like a sea turtle it's moving too
fast and sharks generally don't want to
put themselves in the surf line that's
why for the most part you're safe
swimming in the shallows because sharks
don't want to come into ways where
they're gonna get rolled up onto the
beach and get their gills and everything
else damaged so it's good that it's a
tiger shark
it's accurate that it's possible that
could attack a surfer it's bad that it's
doing when she's standing up on a wave
at second look having been bitten by two
different sharks myself never anything
that bad I can tell you that looks like
the way that it would go right so though
the shark would never come up and knock
her off her board but at this point
where she's swimming she's thrashing
she's making commotion on the surface
now she looks like an injured fish or an
injured marine mammal or and injured
turtle the shark comes in for what they
call an investigation bite we have hands
and fingers right if we want to figure
something out we pick it up and go hey
check it out this is a remote right if
you're a shark you're doing that with
your teeth yeah I got bitten here this
year when I was out doing extincter live
working with tiger sharks this bite was
from a lemon shark this guy came and
lunged at me to go for my arm and I just
pulled back and just caught a single
tooth on the side of his mouth if I had
been another second that would have been
my hand gone for sure
the dead whale totally so alright I'm
gonna hold that right there
all right now it's adding up right so
now we've got a tiger shark that's
attacking and eating because there's a
dead whale now there's two pieces to
this puzzle will there be sharks around
a whale carcass absolutely but are they
going to bother attacking something
thrashing and swimming around when
they've got an entire whale to feed on
questionable that's why I say there's no
right or wrong answer they absolutely
could that instinct could be triggered
they could see that splashing go I want
that fresh meal or they could be so full
of whale and lazy and know that they've
got this buffet lunch over here that
they're not even gonna think about the
thing surfing that being said if I'm
finding a dead wheel on a beach in Costa
Rica I'm not surfing anywhere near it
talk about a bad place to be trapped
stuck on top of a dead whale floating in
the ocean with a shark bite so right
there I can see the bite on Earth I
write first of all that's in a bad place
there's some major arteries there that
could be cut you can bleed out but the
shark that I saw in the wave earlier
you're talking about a 13 or 14 foot
tiger shark right the jaw of a 14-foot
tiger sharks this wide so if that's
putting your thigh in its mouth it's
taking most of the thigh with it you
know there are those investigation and
release bites like I mentioned earlier
but the way that it grabbed and pulled
that's going to rip flesh as it pulls
down right so that bite is not accurate
for the scene we saw earlier what you're
looking at is a bite of something that
took a nibble that's maybe five feet
long as opposed to something that's 15
foot long and dragged her underwater
that entire thigh would be missing based
on the scene we saw earlier
all right I've never seen jaws so let's
watch the ending of it let's hold it
there for a second you can see this this
toilet paper roll of a shark that's
launching out of the ocean and basically
sinking the back of the ship now that's
grounded in the thought that you know
sharks like in Seal Island don't they'll
launch out all the way to kill prey I
get that but no shark is ever going to
attack a boat that's four times the
length of it and beach itself to try and
sink the boat you're putting way too
much faith in the animals intelligence
and desire to get something off of that
boat yeah you know it's not bad it
doesn't look great but you know the
white around the jaw the size of the
teeth the pointyness the snout it looks
like a great white shark it doesn't look
fake chomping on board bits I don't
think so the notion that this animal
would just be sitting up on the bow on
the stern of the boat just flopping its
head back and forth like pac-man just
kind of Hungry Hungry Hippos anything
that falls down the boat is cartoonish I
can't think of any other way to describe
it that animal would get one bite of net
and board and be out of there in a
heartbeat it doesn't want to eat those
things
so all right look let's break it down
we've got this monster murderer great
white right he's way too big he's way
too plastic he's smart enough to
bodyslam a boat to sink it and then go
Hungry Hungry Hippos on everything that
falls into his mouth and then he gets a
bite of flesh right whatever it is it's
this guy he's gonna chomp it and then he
retreats I mean there's so many things
wrong with it right a shark would never
behave like that it's never gonna put
itself in that much risk but more
importantly I think big picture is why
why would this animal do that that is so
much more work than swimming you know a
couple feet away to the seal rookery and
grabbing himself a nice tasty snack it's
funny to even consider this reality and
maybe in the 70s when this movie was
made and we had a very poor
understanding of shark behavior then
sure but nowadays we know that great
white sharks have no interest in eating
people if you swim with great white
sharks and clear water they're not going
to attack you they know that you're not
on the menu the only instances where
people get attacked by white sharks and
when they're either provoking them or
when there's a case of misidentification
usually because the water is very dirty
so this whole notion is pretty
ridiculous so I've now seen clips of
Jaws clips of the shallows to movies
I've never seen before but I've now seen
the clips of them and thumbs down for me
as far as that wildlife behavior goes
all right this is Jumanji the big mean
crocodile
[Music]
told that dev for a sec so I've worked
with a lot of crocodiles and I've never
seen one with stegasaurus spikes coming
off of his back like that before that
thing is ultra mean but you know this is
a fantasy movie nobody's saying that
this is you know the actual wilds of
Africa he goes to a whole new world
called Jumanji and maybe in that world
these animals do behave differently and
they have big back spikes I know it's a
crocodile it's it's not an alligator
there's a couple reasons one is we're
seeing all African animals in Jumanji
right there's no alligators in Africa
but secondly crocodiles are the ones
that are dangerous to people alligators
don't hunt large mammals like people but
in this situation in the Jumanji film
here this animal is actually actively
hunting Robin Williams and family so
when he turns the corner based on the
fact that he's from Africa with all the
other African animals and he's hunting
people this is a croc
I'm gonna hold it there so here's
something kind of funny now everybody's
gonna think I'm crazy for saying this
but of all these movies that I've seen
the comedy Jumanji movie with the fake
croc from the alternate universe of
Jumanji is probably the most realistic
in behavior so far I've seen and been
hunted by crocodiles obviously they
haven't got me but I've seen them
hunting and that slow motion along the
surface that keeping the eye level down
to the water that totally cueing in on
the prey source that's all really
accurate as far as how a crocodile would
actually come in to attack something
even the bite and the attack they're
dropping underwater before attacking the
prey so that the prey doesn't know which
direction it's coming from coming up
jaws open for the bite it's pretty good
let's just hold it there Crocs are very
mobile and they're very agile he's not
just gonna sit there while something's
pushing on his jaws he's gonna do one
little flick of the head and he's got
you no problem at all so the idea that
stay away from the pointy end using your
feet to keep the jaws away that
absolutely would hold there for a second
now interestingly when you think of
telling these stories of these big scary
animals like we saw in the grey like we
saw in Jaws and like we saw an anaconda
all those animals are super sized like
they're way too big they're double the
size or in case of anaconda three or
four times the size what the animals
actually get - this one's not when you
see a crocodile this size where his head
takes up most of Robin Williams torso
that tells me that you're looking at
about a 20-foot crocodile which is very
real there are 20-foot crocodiles out
there so at one point you see you know
Robin Williams has his arms around the
crocodiles jaw now interestingly enough
he could actually do that the animal has
an incredible bite force going down but
they do not have a lot of muscles for
opening their jaw I've been able to hold
like 15 foot crocodile's jaws shut just
with two hands like that so holding
animal's jaws shut the animals now in
trouble right so it goes into typical
crocodile behavior something called a
death roll and you see that as he
submerges with Robin Williams and you
see it start to roll now when a
crocodile attacks what it does is it
bites onto something and then it rolls
and it rips the flesh or rips the limb
off something and then the animal
leads out and it eats so they use it as
a defensive mechanism as well as you're
seeing here to try and shake Robin
Williams off of the Crocs so that's it's
actually pretty good it's actually
anatomically pretty correct so I've
watched a bunch of the clips now and
I've seen a lot of different stuff some
of its anatomically correct some of its
correct in behaviors but overall what
I've seen is you know a demonizing of
animals which I really don't like to see
because animals are wonderful incredible
creatures and I can understand why you
do that it tells a good story and it
makes for a good movie but as long as
people can realize the difference
between how great animals really are and
a Hollywood animal I think you're okay